in the wake of the parkland Florida mass
shooting Dick's Sporting Goods is taking
a hard stance and has made the decision
that it is not going to sell assault
style rifles as well as making some
other changes to their gun sales policy
in their dicks sporting goods stores and
now you might be saying well what other
stores are there I will get to that in a
little bit we learned that the parkland
shooter bought a gun at Dick's last year
although it wasn't the kind of gun that
was ultimately used in the shooting and
here's their CEO Edwards stack on Good
Morning America telling George
Stephanopoulos about the change they're
making and why exclusive interview with
Ed stack he's the chairman and CEO of
Dick's Sporting Goods the nation's
largest sporting goods retailer and just
moments ago he released an open letter
announcing the Dick's will no longer
sell assault-style rifles no longer sell
firearms to anyone under 21 years of age
no longer sell high-capacity magazines
he's here to explain why good morning ed
thanks is a dramatic move tell us why
you're taking it well
thanks for for having me today to talk
about this and as we - as we looked at
what happened down in parkland and we
were we were so disturbed and saddened
by what happened
we felt we really needed to do something
and so we've decided not to sell these
assault weapons any longer in any of our
stores and the other things that we
talked about yeah and and in the shooter
down in Parkland actually bought a gun
and a dick store not the assault weapon
right he did and he bought a shotgun
from us back in in November and it
wasn't the gun nor was the type of gun
that that he used in the shooting but
when that happened we realized that the
system and we did everything by the book
we did everything that the law required
and still he was able to blaze on he was
able to buy it was still able to buy a
gun and when we looked at that we said
the systems that are in place across the
board just aren't effective enough to
keep us from selling someone a gun like
that and so we've decided that what
we're not going to sell the assault type
rifles and so they're still going to
sell firearms this is still a good thing
the full list of changes again as was
mentioned there which we're putting up
on the screen for you includes that they
are no longer going to sell assault
style right
fools they're no longer gonna sell
firearms to anyone under 21 no
high-capacity magazines and they never
have and never will sell bump stocks
that allow semi-automatic weapons to
fire more rapidly I actually do think
that 18 to 21 makes a difference the
level of maturity for a 21 year old
compared to an 18 year old in many cases
it's pretty different you're going from
a high school senior or college freshman
to someone potentially almost done with
four years of college not for everybody
I know people who were just as immature
21 as they were at 18 but big picture
that that does make a difference this is
the right decision there's a lot of
calculated marketing and PR here right
and first of all it's that Dix has a
sister store called Field & Stream and
every indication is that Field & Stream
is making no changes to what's available
there and Field & Stream is really more
the place where people go at a higher
rate to buy guns than regular dick
stores but what surfaced is a result of
this story is that tons of people had no
idea that Dick's sold guns at all and I
admit I don't go to Dick's often about a
year ago the bike that I keep in Western
Massachusetts was stolen and I went to
Dick's to buy a new bicycle and I have
no recollection of seeing guns there
maybe the Hadley Massachusetts location
just doesn't sell the guns I'm not
saying they don't sell them I just don't
remember seeing them but the gun
fetishists are furious with dick saying
well now we're going to boycott Dick's
and this is a terrible decision that
they're making I say go ahead and
boycott them right this is fundamentally
a business decision this is the free
market that the Wright claims to push
for Dick's is free to do whatever they
want in terms of what they do and don't
sell within the law based on what's best
for them and I believe that this is
mostly Dick's making a business and PR
decision because it's not fix is a huge
company right it's not like the company
policy reflects the moral views of any
individual or a vice president or the
CEO or whoever they get together in a
room and they make a business decision
about what's best for the Dick's brand
meaning for their business and this is
what they came up with I agree with the
decision if you bigpictures support the
rights of businesses to make decisions
in the market then you've got to support
Dick's doing this you might choose not
to go to Dick's as a result of the
decision but the speed with which the
American
that claims to be for the free market
and private business sovereignty starts
going crazy on companies when they make
the decisions that are best for them is
just laughable yeah I don't really feel
comfortable questioning the motives of
the CEO of Dick's Sporting Goods because
I'm sure he was disturbed by the partial
shooting of course but this has been
going on for a long time and
assault-style rifle rifles have always
been the choice of these mass shooters
for a lot of us just starting now and to
be clear yeah
handguns the causes the guns involved in
most individual instances where someone
is killed or injured with a gun but the
assault style rifles much more common in
the mass shootings and I I agree in the
sense that I just don't think the
decision really relates to the moral
rectitude of the CEO I believe what the
guy says but I think that the broader
decision here is a business decision and
a PR decision and a marketing decision
and one that they're completely entitled
to make so good for them I'm curious
about Field & Stream though doesn't it
doesn't seem like anything's changing
there the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad